You
See what brings you in to the cathedral today one moment. Oh my head popped off
That did not happen before
No matter
Let's me
You know life is really
Hello, sorry, I tend to lose my head
You will have to turn me up I will tell you that right now
Because if I turn myself up I will peek
Also make sure you have the feature turned off that
Limits ASMR the go to your settings on the video
You can send me your mirrors one of them
I don't I don't know why my head's not sticking
It's very weird it was sticking before I literally had no issues before I started stream
I was like, oh, let me get this all set up really fast
So I don't worry about it later and have to keep moving my head around but it doesn't matter. I'm still losing my head
I almost burst out laughing
All right, hold on. Oh come on. There we go
This family curse of ours it's it's very intense
I believe the setting is it's called a stable volume so make sure that that is turned off
Turn off stable volume to better enjoy ASMR streams in general
Let me see if I some of you might have noticed I had the game I was trying to check my audio with an unlisted stream
But some of you saw it before I can market as unlisted because it didn't let me market as unlisted
You little cheeky things sneaking into my enlisted stream trying to test my audio
It was about four of you and I kicked you out real quick
Let's me see
Because I wanted to do all this before I started but it doesn't seem to matter anymore
Because if I turn up my gain any higher you're going to hear a buzz and it's not a good buzz
Anything past a certain point doesn't sound right
Unless I come very close to you or if I talk in my normal speaking voice
Yeah, yeah, make sure you turn it off
Sounds good. Good. Are we fine? Are we good? Are we good and fine then? Are we decent?
I can't believe my head popped up. That's so embarrassing
You can hear a buzz. Okay, I'm turning it back down then
So, just max out all your audio. It doesn't matter
You'll survive
How is the church ambiance? Does it sound all right?
And now, more ambiance
Any issues since the squish mellow? Not that I know of
I have the squish mellow above my desk instead
Yes, the Veeveb does sound nice. This is from the Tel Veeveb plugin
My outfit you see today is from Booth and the background I'm using is from ArtStation
It is linked in the description and then I'm using some wonderful assets from just VTube Studio natively
So, we don't get geekier girlies. If you want to make your ASMR streams more interesting
You can just throw in a couple of things just to kind of make the ambiance a little bit better
That is a lovely rosary. Thank you. Thank you. It was passed down from my mother
The ads all blow my ears
My brother in Christ, why do you not have an art blocker yet? I don't understand
So, I have some, I don't know if you can hear the Gagorian chants in the background
But I have Gagorian chants in Rain Sounds playing. It's probably very quiet, but that is fine
I don't care too much. The video will probably get claimed no matter what, because it was strikes, I don't know
But I will continue to provide the best ASMR that I can
You don't hear any chanting?
What about now?
I just start screaming my head off
Okay, yeah, it's supposed to be some fireplace ambiance, some like writing and chanting, like little subtle chanting
I'm going to turn it down just a tad, because I don't want it to overpower
When you hear the same thing looped over and over again, it can be quite grating I would say
So, you thought it was the voices again
But hello, if you are new here, my name is Bibi Kuddlebun
I am the sister of Shibi Kottenbaum, I will be taking over her channel today
I live as a nun in the UK, and it is very nice to meet you all and giving me the chance to spread the Lord's good word to you all
This is a great Zelda impression, that is Zelda British, I don't understand
But anyways, this will mostly be a talking and chatting and role-playing stream
If you are more interested in getting ASMR triggers, I am sorry
But there will not be a lot besides maybe some ear cupping
Or some finger fluttering, the sound of holy water
Me doing unintelligible whispers, and also reading your marrows
So we will, if you want to stick around, you can, and I would appreciate you being here
Again, I am from the UK, so I will be speaking in a different accent than you are normally used to
If you misunderstand me, or if you cannot understand what I am saying, I apologise
I know it can be difficult for you to listen to my sister's colleague, Strawny, because she is from Scotland
So I will try my best to enunciate and act accordingly
Yes, I may be speaking in tongues, we will see
How is accents different from shebees, their sisters?
Again, I was, so our mother, you guys know that our family is quite large
And my mother was worried that we were becoming corrupted
So she sent me and my sisters away from each other, so that the corruption could not spread
So I was raised by a distant relative in the UK
Shebe was raised in America, Shebevely was raised in Canada
Because we have family all over, so that is the reason why we sound different from each other
Shebe has a relative without a foul mouth, of course, of course
I don't know what they call it, I am what they call, what do the Japanese say?
Say so, I am what they call, I am say so
I am uncorruptible, I am very thankful for being able to draw closer to God
And I hope that I can assist those who have strayed from his light today
I may be reading you some scripture, and I may be doing some other things, so we will see
This is an improv role play, by the way, so I apologise in advance
And if you are offended by this, get over yourself, that's all I am going to say
Sorry for repeating, but is there a reason you have a different last name, is there a Mr or Mrs Cuddlebomb?
I changed my last name to disassociate myself from the Cottonbomb family
Cottonbomb is quite an unseemly last name in my opinion, and I am a lot sweeter than my sisters
I know my sisters can carry themselves a little crudely at times
We have only just started growing closer again, so I have recently started associating with my sister
She has cleaned up her act and she has gotten a job running a hotel, and I am quite proud of her
So I have come from the UK to see her endeavours, I have been here for a couple of days now
Some of you have seen me here and there, my sister has stolen my outfit a few times
When she was playing another video game, very rude of her, very rude, but I forgive her, as the Lord says
We forgive our brother's transgressions, and I will do so
How can an innocuous nun ever offend anyone? I don't know, I don't know
I don't know, I think the hotel, yes, yes, the hotel seems very busy
So I am very thankful to have, I don't know why she calls you this, but the harem here today
To listen to my ASMR
I heard from Shabbatani the herna siblings live with you
Oh, her siblings still live with me, two of her older brothers and her older sister stay with me
They are not as well behaved as I would like, but it is very hard being a single aunt raising three young adults
Your sister says you are doing good at dealing with werewolves
What did my sister tell you about werewolves?
I want to hear nothing about werewolves
I don't, I don't want to talk, I don't want to talk about werewolves
Yes, I've had to stave off an infestation from the church, it was a long and hard fight
Vampires are no different
Are you down with the fever? Oh no, bless you for asking though
Alright, shall we begin?
I will introduce you to the church
Let me hold it on, there we go
Thanks
So this is the church of Saint Lapin
The church is very old, it could use some more love and care
We have some nuns, usually down that hallway where the nun's quarters are
Up above you see there is where the nun's quarters are
And then across the way is the library
You can see it seems like brother Michael has left his books out, but it is fine
And then we also have a lot of, we are run by many different monks
We have Saint, not Saint, brother Michael, Luke and John
And they are the ones that oversee this establishment
But yes, Saint Lapin is a very important saint for the Bonne people
And I pray to Saint Lapin every day that he removes my family's curse of being a Dullahan
We still don't know how to break said curse, it is the work of the devil I swear
But what more can you do really besides have faith?
So I will continue to have faith
You have sinned
I have asked for some of you to send me your confessions
I will read said confessions a little later time
But for now I shall give you your, I shall read you some scripture
And you can tell me now in the chat what sins you are wishing to be absolved of
The more darker ones you can reserve for the Marshmallow as they call it
It can be really handy to be able to detach your head, I suppose, but sometimes it just gets in the way
I can be, you know, working on writing and taking notes and then my head falls off
So it is, it can be a little bit more, just the time, just the time
The sins of your lust
Oh yes, one of the most gravest sins are the sins of the flesh
So I can pull up some scriptures for you in that we can meditate on them together
I spit right outside the doorway of Walmart on the way out
Why would you do such a thing?
Why is it a sin? Why is it so?
Well, you have to think, so
God made us in his holy image and in his own holy image
We have to be, you know, as they say, treat ourselves like a temple
We have to treat our bodies with respect
And if you go on defiling your body by using it lustfully
Out of wedlock, it is bad in the eyes of God
You just saw a man spit inside the doorway
The sister sounds more English than anyone from my hometown and I'm from an English market town
Well, it depends, I have a unique regional dialect
I know one of my nephews is from London and he has a stronger street accent
Not very proper of him
Madam Shibi defiles us quite a bit
I do not know what you speak of and I do not think I want to know what you speak of
My sister has told me she has changed her ways but it seems like she has not
In one of our bodies is recreated as a temple of Aphrodite
Oh, my sweet, sweet pagan
Aphrodite is a pagan god, the one true god is our lord and his son Jesus
So you will not be recreated in the body, the temple of Aphrodite
As she is a false god, a false witness and a work of the devil actually
What region? Don't ask, I'm not that smart
My cloth is quite distracting
I don't know what you speak of, I am wearing the normal vestments of my order
Although, it seems to have made my skin a little old
I am wearing very white, what is it called?
Tight
I do not look too closely then
I would hate to cause you to stumble
They say if your right eye is causing you to stumble, rip it out and throw it away from you
Figuratively of course, but it means to remove yourself from the situation
So if I am too distracting, then perhaps you should look away from me
Did I commit some sort of sin for my cat to run away from me while wearing shoes?
I do not know which of what you speak, it is quite confusing what I have just read
Sister BB, do you also preach? Is that for the brothers of St. Philippine?
I mostly spend my days meditating on scripture, drawing closer to God
and bonding with him through prayer, maintaining the church halls and organising
I do a lot of what is similar to my sister, she we accepted to church and not a hotel
I make sure everything is nice and clean and dandy and all that stuff
As a woman, I am of the weaker vessel as they say
So I do not have a place preaching or holding salmon, but that is okay
I do make time to teach the little ones in our congregation and teach and help the women that attend the church
The other bunny girls are quite, you have to understand we are bunny people
There are quite a lot of children that need to be raised in the knowledge of the Lord
Sister, can we start a holy crusade in your name bringing your image to the savages?
Well, the Bible says that idolatry is a sin
So I wouldn't recommend using me as a sort of idol
Go on preaching yourself and spreading the news of Jesus Christ and all his miraculous works, I would say
Sister, baby, I am tempted to sin every time I look at feet and armpits
How can I cleanse myself of these thoughts?
Very interesting to ask
I do not know why these things would cause you to sin as they are just extensions of our body
And maybe I am assuming that you are seeing them in a lustful way
So in order to see them in not a lustful way, you have to think of them as what they are
Just aspects of your body, tools to be used, feet to help you walk, armpits to help you sweat
And I think when you break it down into its most simplest form, then you will be able to combat these foul thoughts
Sister, baby, does it hurt to offer a flagellation as penance?
Perhaps personal flagellation by you sister?
Oh yes, of course, of course we offer that
I had a younger disciple in the past do a similar speech to mine that I am talking about right now
And she was very into self-flagellation and we have adopted the practice
So yes, I do have some whips and flails to participate in helping you be repented upon your sins
Perhaps we can do that towards the end of our teachings today
The flagellation is one of the most important and amazing acts one can do on to God
You are giving yourself pain and washing yourself with your blood with his holy love
And God looks down on you with warmth and praise as he sees what you have put yourself through to make good on what you have done
You certainly need to be corrected, I suppose
Do not fall for the honey words, sister, the only fit pleasure of getting whipped by a sister of the cloth
I'm not quite sure about that, I think I'll take their word for it, they seem like good folk
It's being a non-common practice among bunny women, there are a few of us, not too many
But there are quite a few again, only people are very, very abundant
So it's not hard to find us in varying jobs in careers, I would say
The only pleasure I feel is the pleasure of being washed of mind, son
Oh and you know, I have just something for that, so give me just a second
I have it
Sister, are you at all familiar with the God of the cloth?
No, I'm not
I'm not
I love it
Sister, are you at all familiar with the goddess known as Azera?
I don't believe in any false gods, I do not know of it whom you speak of
I have seen a very large, voluptuous woman hanging out with my sister, but I do not
I don't know if that's who you're referring to, because I have heard my sister call her by the same name
What relation are you to Shibi, she is my twin sister, or triplet really, we are of three
Who let a cat into the church?
Whatever, God loves all his pitiful creatures
Excuse me sir, I'm going to have to ask you to leave the premises
Yes you, Mr Kitty Cat
Please, you are...
Excuse me
Why are you so large for a cat?
You're more like a little lion cub
God, I want Shibi to sit on my fuck three
I don't know what that means
I will pass the message along to her though
Sister Bebe, does one need to worry about birth control after being failed at the brim of Christ's love?
Or has he had the SNP?
I don't know what birth control has to do with God's and Christ's love, but I pray you be filled by Christ constantly
That's all I have to say about that
Must have been Helman, Kiz, and my mother, Bunny, the Shelter, Shibi and Bebe
Well, it is kind of the custom to have the types of names that we do
Sorry, pardon, I have itchy eyeball
But we were usually called more colourful names by our mother growing up so it wasn't hard to differentiate
Mysterious Bumi
I've heard of this Bumi, I've heard he is something of a highwayman, robber, a thief, a menace
I'm not quite sure though
But anyways, forever
Going back to what I was going to do before
I have some holy water
So let me wash your sins away
Come close, here, let me pull your face close
Hi there
Oh, you are a looker, aren't you? You are quite handsome and beautiful
God created you well, didn't he?
Your friends must be jealous of you
Hopefully not too envious because envy is a sin
So I want you to close your eyes and just let God's love in his holy water wash over
I wish I was an artist so I could draw Sister Bee Bee kneeling down in front of the altar with mouth open and tongue out ready to receive communion
Oh, that would be absolutely lovely actually
I always receive communion on my knees
Do not worry, you do not need to be a follower of the faith to be cleansed by the holy water of God
Through his love Jesus Christ will heal you and heal all your wounds
Do I receive and join our communion?
Of course, of course I do
It is always my pleasure to be able to take a piece of God's flesh, Jesus's flesh in my mouth
It is a holy right and one that I am thankful to be able to participate in
I am not someone you can confess to in a confessional, dear brother
You would have to speak to one of the priests
But maybe I'd be able to arrange something
God someone please get this cat out of here
I think I got a loose cat
I think I got a loose cat hair in my eye
And it is itchy
These random street cats just keep coming into the church
But what can you do?
The cat must have been sent by the Lord
Maybe, who knows?
God loves all his creatures
Sister, I must confess
Your twin sister makes me want to break my vows at all now
Please forgive me
What vows, sweet child
What vows, my dear
Admit them to me
What thoughts have you been having?
I ask only of concern, am I sweetling?
Sister, I haven't ever prayed before
Will you help me do my knees and teach me how?
Of course
It is quite easy to get on your knees to pray
Especially if you overcome by the Lord
And His Holy Spirit
Something seems wrong
I feel, I feel a dark energy over me
And over you
Look into my eyes
Have you been cursed?
Have you been doing unrighteous things?
There is a darkness over you
Something doesn't seem right
I might have to call a priest to perform an exorcism
What have you done, you sinner?
How did you come to be, come to have such a sinful nature?
Highly suspicious
I don't know what this is
I might need to get more holy water
You were corrupted
Fall into sin, tempted by strongy and hypnotism
Strongy, strongy
That name sounds familiar
She's the Scottish, is she not?
Yes
A wicked devilish thing
Using her guiles to hypnotise
Simple men
Into doing her whims
It must be an act of the devil
You feel like you have been cursed for a long time
Don't worry, I will fix that
I will save your wavering soul, sweet thing
The Lord's light shall play you from the shadows
And reveal your golden innocence once more
I will save you, my child
Let me get some more holy water
I'm getting myself wet, oops
I'm soaking myself
There's the mist setting on this holy water bottle
There it is
Probably should have brought a towel
Now am I more wet?
Be cleansed
I will not let you go so easily to the devil
There's no end to some holiness
I think I keep stumbling over my words
Because you are so close to my face
I think I have to back up
This is unseemly to be seen so close to you
I do not want the members of the church getting the wrong idea
I'm getting myself wet
Please cleanse my soul, Sister Beepie
And lead me towards the path of forgiveness
And away from temptation
I want you just that
Hello, Sister, as in none, are you small to just to do?
Of course I am
Hello, Evelynx
Oh, it is the seductress we talked about earlier
It is Strawny Cuddles
She of the devil
Co-hypnotises men to bow to her every whim
Interesting
I'm surprised she would leave her followers on the house of God
I will cleanse them
You are respectful and pray
It is good to see you repentant, Succubus
I will take care of your former worse
And I will cleanse them
And I will guide them
And guide them to God's light
You sweet, weary souls
You wayward ones
Go on, or draw you close
Like a shepherd, draw closest to his sheep
I keep stumbling over my words
I don't know why
I go to say something and it comes out not the way I wanted it to
But you know what I mean
Maybe I'll start calling you my little lambs
Just as Jesus was a shepherd to us all
We are not but his sheep
His followers, guided by his staff of knowledge and righteousness
Now that you have been cleansed by the holy waters
I suppose I shall wipe you clean
And wipe away the sin from your flesh
Why are you barring?
Is that when my sister has you do, she has you bar for her?
I suppose that's well enough
She has you bark for her
And they're wondering what she have you do to her
I'm well, she probably
Don't mind
Do not say such things
That is blasphemous
The scriptures say man cannot lie with an animal
Psalms 23 verse 4
Yes, though I walk through the valley
And the shadow of death
I fear no evil
For thou art with me, thy rod
And thy staff, they comfort me
I'm waft comforted by God's rod and staff
The staff can be firm, yet gentle
Guiding, nudging us along
On the path to righteousness
Does that apply to animal folk like me?
No, I am only partially animal, I would say
I am mostly human like some of you
Just with some added bonuses
Surely you don't count as an animal despite being funny
Right, this is BB, may we lie with you?
I can't believe you would ask such a coarse and lewd thing
I'm a sister of the cloth, I lie with no man or woman
Be so kind
I'm being walked
Sometimes it's more than a nudge
Yes, that is correct
Sometimes it's more like a thrust
And a thrust by such a rod
Can bring anyone to a righteous room
And finish them completely
Wipe away the sand
Wipe away the sea
be glassy, be glassy, be glassy
sista, if God doesn't want you to be glassy, then be glassy
sista, if God doesn't want me to sin, why did he make you so adorable?
if God works in mysterious ways, sweet one, I do not know why God made me this way, but
I did to keep my body to him, to worship and love, just as Mary, a holy mother did, I follow
and have footsteps. You feel the burden of your sins getting lighter and lighter, lighter,
and lighter, lighter, and lighter, lighter, and lighter.
How many Hail Mary's and Lord's prayers until I'm forgiven, sista, I do not know what your sin is, sweet one.
You must tell me, darling, what you have done, so that I may assign them accordingly.
It's a test. There is often a woman placed in front of someone, beautiful, desirable.
You may want to indulge in such a woman, but God places these obstacles before you as a test, to test your will.
You must find. You must find.
Perhaps it was God's plan for me to be a sinner, so you could cleanse me of yourself. Perhaps I do not know why God does what he does.
I only knew as he asked, any place you in front of me, and I will take care of you, and I will save your filthy soul.
My will was broken by your sista. What did she do to you, my dear, that your will was broken?
Even the lowest man can find God.
Sista, I must confess, when I'm with you, I have such lost a lot. Forgive me.
Then I do say to you, brother, turn away from me, do not look upon my figure, if it causes you to stray.
I do not mind if you look, but if it stumbles you, I would hate to be the cause.
As God has made such beautiful creatures and His creation so that they can be admired.
But what if we can't resist because of our love? Love isn't a sin, right?
Of course not, my dear. Love is essential.
Through God's love we were given Jesus Christ to wash away our sins.
He gave His only begotten Son for us to save us from ourselves.
There is such a righteous love instilled within all of us, and it is important that we use it, whether it be platonically or romantically,
because in this God's will that we fill the earth with all its loving worshipers.
Fellow believers, do not confuse the lustful, craving, possessive love in Greek horrors.
For God's perfect, unselfish, loving-liners in Greek.
Look on, Barry. That is true, but well.
As my sister says, don't get it twisted.
No, I will not show you my feet in armpits.
I may have to call a priest for you, I think you are too far gone.
Forgive my sin, because I'm coming late to your stream. I'm glad that you came.
Oh sister, I have strayed from our holy ideology. What can I do to come back to the light?
I think you misspelled the word ideology, but I will answer the question nonetheless.
I'm sorry you have strayed, but you are strong, you are tough, you are one of God's warriors,
and he puts you on this earth for a reason, to fight, to fight against evil temptation,
to fight against the evil in the world that could destroy us all, but it is only us, true believers,
that stand against the devil and put to need to protect his innocent ones.
Take up the holy sword, brother. Use it to slay the wicked, preach God's word, and draw close to him as he draws closer to you.
Sister, why must God give me the hardest tasks, like washing my dear face and making my bed?
Oh, God gives the hardest tasks to his hardened soldiers, of course. Aren't you funny one?
You've been instilled with some sort of wit. It is quite humorous.
Blessed be his gifts of love he has bestowed upon me, for I have found true love in one and true friendships in others.
Amen, amen, amen. Beautifully said, beautifully put.
Sister, what if I slay demons by working with demons, like in the hit video game Diablo 4?
Those who are different sorts of demons, so I think you're fine.
I do not recommend using or playing works involved with the devil, but again, we are imperfect sinners.
Mother, baby, I'm sister, I'm no mother, but thank you. I hope to become a mother one day, spiritually.
I mean, spiritually. Have you ever encountered a demon? How did you survive? How can you fight the supernatural?
Oh, I have quite the story for that. Once upon a time, I was alone in my room. I had just said my nightly prayers.
Sorry, my cat knocked over everything.
Oh my God. I am so sorry.
No, it wasn't even boomy. It was rain and boomy, actually. I need to get a towel, expeditiously.
Oh, wait for this.
Oh, boomy. I'm no catty. Oh, boomy. It's okay. It's okay. It's okay.
Sorry.
You're fine.
Okay. Oh, it's nothing.
One of the cats is a giant puffball right now because one of them knocked over my iPad and they spilled my drink all over my mousepad and it's probably going to be broken now.
It keeps up the accent in the distance.
Yes, I had a drink and he spilled it everywhere. I might have to get a new mousepad. I'm quite disappointed.
The same thing happened on Icy's stream. Oh, that poor heatheness polar bear child thing. That's too bad.
No, there's no ribbon glass, don't worry.
It's just a wet lemonade stain. It smells good, at least. You, not so much.
I believe Raina was boomy and boomy knocked over my drink. Raina knocked over my trash can and iPad. She knocked my iPad off my desk.
Sending boomy into a tizzy.
I knocked over my drink. Let's see if she broke my iPad.
Did she break it? No, she didn't. Okay, that's all I care about. I don't feel like spending another $600 on an iPad, although I've had this one for a couple of years, but it's fine.
It's gotten its use, but I would rather not get rid of it so quickly.
Just in the words, I'm sorry, that's all I can say.
The strong is this devilish succubus, this Icy is a heathen. I think I saw something about Imi. She is also a worker of the devil practicing spiritualism.
Terrible acts. Azura claims to be a false god. It's terrible.
And Massey. Massey is spiritually disturbed. She needs Jesus.
iPad and a monastery. It's so easy to have my Bible on my iPad. I don't know what you're talking about. I can take it with me so I don't have to bring the Bible from the church to my home.
Not that I don't have a paper Bible. I've quite a few. Very multiple editions, actually.
I think she is an agent of Satan. You can't see, but I just did the cross.
I don't think that cat will be coming back from some time. He seemed quite frightened. I feel a little bad.
Sister, I have a confession to make. I enjoy my spaghetti with ketchup rather than pasta sauce. Please forgive my transgressions.
The Italians will kill you. Not in Minecraft. The iPad was not blessed with holy water, no.
Sorry. I don't even remember what I was talking about. Oops, I'm going bigger. Excuse me.
Oh, I was talking about one of the interactions I've had with the devil, with demons.
You're sleeping with that vicious skin.
I'd like to know your location. I love Assassin's Creed.
Anyways, let me start my story over. Let me make the Gregorian chant a little louder. Just so God can heal, I must protect myself as I say this.
Even my sister, I know, has worked alongside the devil. I do not doubt it. I do not doubt she sold her soul to rise in power at this Wonderland hotel.
Once upon a time, at night, I was lying in my bed, having just said my nightly prayers, praying for everyone's souls, and for forgiveness of my own transgressions.
I heard a knock at the door. I asked who was there. I hadn't expected any company at this time of night. No one answered me. I heard the knock again.
I rose from my bed, in my rose, my nightgown, and opened the door to my bedroom. A great wind rushed in.
I stood, cold, in shock. I could be not such a draft in my home. It would be impossible. I should have never opened the door, for I believe the devil himself came in.
I heard a dark voice call from a corner, aching in the back of my mind.
You are mine, sister. You are mine forever. Even one god, he cannot have came for me. The voice shook me to my core.
Much of her ran down my spine. The Lord is with me. I whispered, clutching my cross closely to my chest. Your Lord cannot protect you now.
I was thrown onto my bed. My clothes ripped. A pressure found itself winding up my legs, to my core, to my belly, to my chest, to my throat.
I was frozen in shock. This pressure was on top of me. Everywhere I could not breathe. I did not have the voice to scream. I could not move. It was as if my hands and my legs were bound.
I prayed silently in my head to the Lord. The voice laughed at me, as if it could read my mind. In them, I cannot speak of what happened next.
It is too much. I was overwrought with sin. My fingers moved as if controlled by this entity. I will not tell you what I did. It is too shameful.
I am sorry to burden you with such a story. Do not worry from my soul. I have cleansed myself appropriately.
Do not fret. I think it is time we read some of your confessions.
I will not tell you what I did.
I will only be reading what I deemed to be safe for work, as my sister calls it.
Forgive me, Sister Bibi, for I have sinned. I have had no dreams about Shibi Kanban, my sister, like waking up in bed before her and going to make breakfast, only to be held in bed by her not wanting to wake up.
To then use the cat as a place to hunt her like an Indiana Jones, and then bring some breakfast to her in bed so we can cuddle.
I think that is quite sweet actually, as long as you dream of being married during this, I think you are okay.
I confess pineapple on pizza is okay sometimes, but only sometimes.
I also confess that the A10 Warthog Thunderbolt 2 goes bird smelly face. I don't know what that is.
Sister, can you marry? No, I have taken a vow of chastity.
I actually like pineapple on pizza. I think it's a nice mixture of savory and sweet when done appropriately, so I will agree with this person when I say sometimes and only sometimes.
Mother Bibi, I am a sister. I am not Abbas. I am struggling a lot with temptation. Is it true that pain can help with dominating lust?
Could you help this poor soul by cleansing it with ritual flagellation? I wish you to straighten my back. Thank you for listening to my confession.
I will do this for you, my poor soul. Towards the end of this stream, I will take my whip and move shall all progress in an act of self-flagellation.
To atone for all the sins that you may have committed, or may be committing as I speak, for right now.
Next one says, I work for YouTube and I made a terrible mistake. I can't tell a rat from a loon scene. Is there any help for me, or am I a reprobate that is going to hell?
I'm so sorry, but I cannot save you. You are simply going to hell for confusing that. To disrespect God's creatures with assuming an act of ludeness had taken place. There is no help for you.
The ultimate question, sister, do you know the Lord's prayer? Yes.
Our Father, your art in heaven, hallowed be thy name, thy kingdom come, thy will be done, as in heaven and earth.
There's more than that, but I don't feel like reciting the whole thing.
Whenever I look at you, I am overwhelmed by impure desires. I desire that you would do unspeakable things to me, things that would make even the Spanish Inquisition look tame, and I think I deserve them all because I am a sinner.
Hello. I am quite flushed right now. I don't know what to say to that. I do not know why I cause so many men to sin. I apologize, but I cannot change who I am.
Maybe I should remove myself so that you are not tempted by my body.
I will do these things to you. I feel like you have a lot to repent for. I shall make sure we have a session at the blue website after this stream to make sure that you can attend for your sins.
I feel that had a fellow woman of the cloth not intervened in kindergarten, I would have grown into the son of Satan himself.
It's the only case of corporal punishment I know that appears to have worked as advertised. I've been a good boy, or a lesser evil one ever since that day.
I have come to confess that my soul still feels guilty to this day, and I fear that the punishment may have not been enough. I fear that the beast I could have been and probably am still may return one day.
Why does that sound like the back of a book you pull off the shelf in a fiction aisle?
My sweet dear sinner, I think you should give yourself more credit. You are already self aware about the negative machinations of the devil. All you must do, my sweet sinner, is avoid what could cause you to stray from his light.
I am not here to confess my sins, but to confess my love. Sister Bebe, will you marry me?
Oh my dear, I am sorry, but I can do no such thing. I am pledged to a lord in my virtue with him.
I apologise, but I am sure you will find a good Christian girl that can take care of you and all of your needs.
Madam Shebe, is that you? No, my sweet. I am Sister Bebe. I am Shebe's sister, actually her twin sister. Oh, the cat has come back. Hello. I think you have one they call Boomi.
Are you done being scared, little Boomi? Come on, you can lie in the bed.
I will save all of your souls.
Sister Bebe, I have a confession to make. I am afraid I am guilty of the sins of lust. You see, I have been losting after Madam Shebe since meeting her.
I often think of worshipping this woman in partaking in unspeakable acts with her. Even now, I have an overwhelming desire to pleasure her.
I fear that I am being overcome with a bounding love. Do you think I can be given, Sister?
Of course, again, dear sinner, you can be forgiven. Love is no sin. It is what you act upon outside the vows of marriage that is a sin.
You may think about it, you may linger, but not too long. It is interesting to me that many of you would think of my sister this way.
I am reading this from Marshmallows. The link is on my Sister Shebe's profile.
You must find something to distract you, something that brings you equal pleasure, and then, perhaps, pray.
Hopefully, the distraction in the fervent reading of God's Word will help you abstain from such thoughts.
I'm sorry, Mummy, I've been bad. I keep having impure thoughts about Madam Shebe. Why are you all talking about my sister? I don't understand.
What does my sister do to you all? Is my sister a sucky bitch? Is she working for the devil? I may have to look into this if so many of you are within her thrall. It is very weird to me, very odd.
Of course, you all can be saved, my dear Synon. You must welcome in Christ, and then you can be truly saved. Turn towards Him. Dedicate yourself to the Lord.
May I hearth your sister's hand in marriage? That is up for her to decide, to be honest with you. You know she is someone who have a mind of her own.
Dear Miss Bebe, I master at least once a day every day. I'm sorry for the similar flash. How may I reduce my sinning?
Any time you go to reach for yourself, you must reach for your Bible instead, and look upon His Word, and I will give you a scripture as an example to reflect on, my dear Synon.
I wish I had my actual Bible with me, because then you would be able to hear the page turning, but I don't have that, it is at my relative's house.
You can hear my nails tap on my holy iPad.
I will read for you 1 Corinthians 6 verses 18-20.
You are not your own, you are bought at a price, therefore honour God with your bodies.
I will expand upon this with Matthew chapter 5, 27 verses 28. It seems a lot of you may need this scripture.
You have heard that it was said you shall not commit adultery, but I tell you that anyone who looks at a woman lustfully has already committed adultery with her in his heart.
So you have a lot of Hail Marys to do for that.
I will expand with Romans chapter 13 verse 14. Rather, clothe yourselves with the Lord Jesus Christ, and do not think about how to gratify the desires of the flesh.
You must meditate upon Jesus instead to fight these desires. That is the only way, Synon.
Yes, it is still adultery, do not look at women, bad.
1 Thessalonians chapter 4 verses 3-4. It is God's will that you should be sanctified, that you should avoid sexual immorality, that each of you should learn to control your own body in a way that is holy and honourable.
Do not pervert the ways of the Lord with your lustful thoughts. Turn away from these things that would cause you to stray in sin.
God help us their pictures of women. That's why you should not be on social media. How could you not fall into temptation? You must remove yourself from social media sites. It is God's will.
I am so sorry that you were assaulted by pizza. Is never having intercourse also a sin? No. It is a holy thing to reserve yourself for God, to remain impure.
Think of the Virgin Mary. Think of those who never did commit the act of sexual gratification. They are raised as saints and canonised.
For the holiness in you too, shall be looked upon God and favoured for your holy dedication to do what's right.
But sister, YouTube is technically social media, does that mean you have to close the stream as well? If I make you stumble then yes, but if not, it is difficult actually, because social media can also be used to spread God's word.
But this YouTube social media is really just a video hosting site, isn't it? Maybe. Because there's comments, a comment section, and you can engage with me. Forget it.
Ezekiel 2320.
I forgot about the scripture.
Let me read it. Ezekiel 23, verse 26. Wait, I'll make you the full chapter, because now I'm interested.
Oh.
There's a whole chapter just about prostitution. The two adulterous sisters. This is very reminiscent of my own two sisters.
Verse 19 says,
Yet, she became more and more promiscuous as she recalled the days of her youth when she was a prostitute in Egypt. There, she lost it after her lovers, whose genitals were like those of donkeys and whose emission was like that of horses. So you longed for the lewdness of your youth when in Egypt your bosom was caressed and your young breasts fondled.
Go forth and be plentiful. Of course, that is a goal, but you must do it the right way.
Honestly, this seems like a good chapter. I might have to meditate and reflect on this chapter. Maybe I should have my sister read this.
I'm probably in Egypt as built different. My sister might be tempted. Never. Never tempted.
It can be something so lustful for dominant women.
Ugh, you are a man.
Why do you lust for dominant women, dominant women undermine their man's headship?
Do you not be swayed by the unnatural order of things?
How do we even do that?
I've heard there are ways there are some supplements you can take, but you haven't heard it from me.
That's the best part though.
Maybe I will have to see for myself.
I do not know what you speak of.
Here's the short hand of this called a Domi Nomi Hosei, chapter one, two, then three.
When the Lord began to speak through Hosei, the Lord said to him, go, marry a promiscuous
woman and have children with her, for like an adulterous wife, this land is guilty of
unfaithfulness to the Lord.
So he married Goma, daughter of Dia Balam, and she conceived and bore him a son.
Again, when you read scripture, you have to read the context of what's happening, because
it seems like the context for this was that he had no other options.
The whole land was unfaithful, there was only harlots around.
Because if you look at verse six, Goma conceives again and give birth to a daughter, then the
Lord said to Hosei, call her low from Ruhama, which means not loved, for I will no longer
show love to Israel, and I should all forgive them.
He was just having a bad day with them.
It just doesn't, he had already forsaken them, so he was like, I don't care what you do,
do whatever, give them all these crappy names.
Because then he had another son, and they named him Lohami, which means not my people.
God was just going off on this family, he's like, I just don't like you, you keep having
kids, keep naming these terrible things.
Yes, except when it's inconvenient.
Who cares about convenience when it's the word of the Lord?
Okay, let me look at more marshmallows.
Sister Bibi, I need your help.
After spending about two months with your sister, Shibi, I cannot stop thinking about
what, sometimes I have been thinking, but you thought, I'm being redundant at this point,
you've heard me what I've said before.
Stop thinking of me, they're my sister, and these dirty matters.
What do I have to do to convince you otherwise?
The Bible says we can buy a doll with some cattle and goats.
Of course, there are things that are outdated in that do not apply to our current time.
They're still applicable, and you just have to find their contemporary meanings.
Forgive me, sister, for I have sinned, I have engaged in carnal pleasures with a certain
bunny woman, what makes my sin even worse is the fact she was in the none of it, what?
The act was very blasphemous, but the worst act of all was when she wiped my seed with
her habit.
Please forgive me, give me penance and free my soul of this sin.
Who was this, it was the sister of my church, I would have to speak with her.
That is absolutely disgusting.
I'm so sorry she took advantage of you, clearly she's not a true woman of the cloth, she has
taken her vestments in vain.
Sister BB, I broken spaghetti in half before cooking, I can't have salad, again, the Italians
are the only ones that can absolve you, you will be murdered for your insolence, I cannot
help you there.
That is not the act of the devil, that is the act of a hatefulness, that is a hatecrime
against the Italian.
The next one, I lost my virginity in an expensive soap land in Japan, great experience, but
was this a sin, forgive me sister BB, I don't know what a soap land is.
Again, it is a sin, when you have sexual relations outside of marriage, then it is a sin, I cannot
believe you.
You know there is this one verse in the bible that says he wept and I went half-same.
It is good to let out your emotions, God has cried for us many a time, why do you think
he gave his son?
Okay, forgive me sister BB for I have sinned, it has been twenty-two years since my last
confession.
Oh well, I had impure thoughts about a relative she be laying down with the...
I cannot read the rest of this, this is atrocious, I, you are damned to hell for this comment,
I can't even read this, why would you say such a thing?
Lying down with a what, a beat I can't even, there is like two more sentences to this,
you are destined for hell, there is no saving your soul, you are lost.
It lets me refresh the page, one of you sent the same thing multiple times, I also can't
read this one either, well, that's terrible, oh my God, I have read this multiple times,
I'll read some of these on blue website, how about that, because I, oh my God, chat reflects
a streamer, I don't know what my sister has been up to, but forgive me sister BB for I
have sinned, I pretended to be mute to not talk to someone, oh, you know, I don't know
actions speak louder than words my dears, sometimes it is better to hold our tongue
than to waggle it and say something that we do not mean, I say that you are forgiven
for such things, is BDSM a sin if I'm married, I do not know what this BDSM is, BDSM, BDSM,
BDSM, BDSM, I don't know, sister BB, I really need your help, every time I come to church
on Sunday and see you, my pants get really tight and my crotch gets really hot, I can't
read this, I, I, I, what is happening, I, I, I am sorry that you feel this way, you
should probably see a doctor, sister, I am in love with a very sweet girl and sometimes
it borders on insanity, I need her every waking moment, I try to temper my thoughts but she
consumes them, again remember that when you think of a woman you are committing adultery,
you must fill your thoughts instead of the Lord instead of this woman that plagues you,
sister BB, can you help out to poor soul, there is this woman that you are committing adultery,
attempts me into sin, she has a very wet mouth and the shells she makes with it are driving
my mortal flesh away from God, how does one resist the wet mouth, I feel like I know who
you speak of, I have run into this woman before, she is quite the seductress herself, her words
on her lips are honey, I do not blame you brother but it will be a hard fight, hmmm,
you must resist her, you must be strong, you must avoid her at all costs, or you will be
lost like all the others, is this a good idea, you madam's male, it's fine, don't worry about
it, alright, a lot of these are stuff that I cannot read, well, guys I said I would be
doing this on YouTube, I don't understand, okay, oh sister I have heard your plight with
the demons, for a very low payment of four twenty dollars and sixty nine cents will bring
in the demon hunter expert Sam and Dean Winchester to exercise the demons, Chevy and Pollard cost
extra, demon hunter ink is not liable for any physical, mental, emotional, spiritual and
quantum damage caused by the exorcism, I have met these two before, they're quite sweet,
I did not like them that much though, I would not hire them again, they blew up the last
chapel I was in, I almost, ugh, didn't make it, my dear sister, be aware that when you
walk into the house of blue it is filled with demons and your faith will be tested, your
every desire will be tended to, you will say a word, you only think your most tempting
thoughts, you might walk out of there corrupted, and if so you will be in utter bliss, so if
you believe your faith is strong come see us from this house of blue, you'll be eagerly
waiting, I've heard of this house of blue, I must see it for myself, I must go, I think
there are many sheep without a shepherd there that I must guide to Jesus, and I will do
so, sister baby for the past many nights I have been plagued with impure thoughts of your
sister when I've given myself to another, I've dreamt many dreams of our bodies intermingling,
I deserve punishment, but I fear the law, I love the painful pleasure of a whip or paddle
against my skin, you are an adulterer and a philanderer, these things will not absolve
you, self-flagellation will not bring you mercy, pardon the pun, I can't, if why do
you look upon my sister if you have given yourself to another, it is either you dedicate
yourself to both, to none or to one, sister how does one atone for burning another church,
you've burned more than one, BDSM, Blessings, Devotion, Service and Mercy, oh okay, I participate
in BDSM then, you can fully display it, I believe so too, I think your sins need to be on full
display, what, I played with my rabbit's lob ears, she was fine with it, but I did feel
a little rude considering, that's fine, as long as the bunny can sense, then you were fine,
sister baby, I've never known a woman, and at this point I think I'm losing it, some days
on the weekends I get to the double digits, handling it myself, the double digits, most
nights I don't even get to sleep if I don't, but the worst if it is, I just want someone
to hold, you have a daemon, there is a daemon within you, there is a darkness, you must
cast it out, you must be exercised, I will be exercising you all at the house of blue,
that is terrible, I'm so sorry, take a breath, breathe brother, breathe, sister I have a
confession, I did a read your ball at a friend's house, pagan I know, did I invite daemons,
yes you did, I'm so sorry about what you did, you're going to have nightmares for like
three days, you can feel very depressed, you better read the bible, burn some sage or whatever
pagans do to get rid of that, careful with the mic peaking a bit, how about you shot
you on holy mouth, how about that, forgive me sister bb5 sin, last week I spent money
on the gacha game blue archive and spent around 80 dollars, I got what I wanted but I feel
sinful now forgive me sister, it seems you got greedy then, you should have stopped that,
these tithes could have been paid to the church instead of this blue archive, I do not know
what this blue archive is, it sounds most unholy, who did you roll for, that's a great
question, please send me your answer, we're worshipping golden in an un-christian way,
I do not know what this means, how can, what churches were worshipping golden in an un-christian
way that you felt so you had to take upon yourself to set them aflame, dress hyena and
well now you know your answers, I thought you were going to send them anonymously but
never mind, no sticks, alright I think I'm done reading the marrows for now because they
have, I cannot read these, forgive me for I have sinned, I am a weak man and can't bring
myself to be loyal to just one girl, instead I have been acting unwise to all the women
in this corporal, how can I redeem myself, out of character I don't care and nobody else
does either, in character, how could you do such a thing, you must be loyal to one woman,
you put down me to hell if you cannot dedicate yourself to one woman, I do not want to spur
any competitiveness amongst ourselves because it, I'll be honest with you, it genuinely
pains me that some of you feel like you cannot love another, send Scottish for a second, breaks
the fourth wall, I'm doing it again but I'm doing it in my accent because I can't, I can't
read in my accent for some reason, it's really hard to get out of it and give you a soul in your body
and your mind and your spirit over to me instead, sister baby, then you won't have to worry about
any of these feeler whores, proper, affectionately derogatory, oh my god, I can't read this, why
are you guys saying such an holy thing, okay, I think it is time we took this conversation
to the house of blue, say something distinctly on British like I regularly visit a dentist
or this food is a little too bland, well British food is bland, I mean I'm back, I have to use the facilities
I need to use the little nuns room, help me, alright, thank you for coming to my not ASMR ASMR
I'm probably just going to relabel this as a 3D or roleplay rather than ASMR because that's really what it was, it was a 3D or roleplay
so I will change the title as such and yes, my sister is nowhere in the facility, do not speak of her
if I go to the blue website I will continue the accent by the way, the whip, oh that's right, hold on
I need to go get the whip
oh my gosh, I almost forgot, hold on, I need to move this cat because he's going to get scared if I do this
hi baby, excuse me little man, you have to go over here, I do not want you to be scared
alright
it is time for you all to atone
lift up your shirt and turn your backs towards me, you must get lashes for your sins
God bless you all and may you stay in his light
take that
have you had enough, I don't think so yet
oh I just whipped myself
oh that got me right in the teeth
oh my nipple
that was more intense than I thought, okay
don't laugh at me
it's not your place to laugh, stop it right now
no
I am purging my own sins because it was a sin doing the stream
now that's how you break a merchant
why is she going harder than she, well you are clearly in need of God's love
I whipped myself again but it was nice, okay I think that's it, I don't want to
my neighbours are probably like what's happening
alright
may you all be within God's glory and wrapped in his embrace and love furthermore
so
I will see you briefly in a moment
in the house of blue
you don't know what that was and that's fine
anyways
goodbye farewell
right now, yes right now I'm going to take about at 6.15 I will be at the house of blue
where do I find the house of blue, somebody tell him
bye bye
later
I will tweet it from my alt account
or she be wall
bye bye
going God's grace
and in his light